[Music]
is the king of the monsters also the
king of the box office four billion
dollars for lucasfilm was it worth it
was wolverine strong enough to support
the entire x-men movie franchise on his
furry back
these movies brought back long dormant
franchises to a planet near you
star trek is one of the most influential
and long-running media franchises of all
time it's easy to forget that the
original star trek television series was
unceremoniously cancelled after its
third season in 1969. star trek gained
cultural momentum in reruns during the
1970s though leading to a brief revival
as an animated series and a planned
return to live-action television called
star trek phase 2. after the box office
success of star wars in 1977 paramount
changed course and relaunched star trek
on the big screen resulting in 1979's
star trek the motion picture the motion
picture was a financial success but a
critical failure whose plotting pace
earned it the fan nickname the slow
motion pitcher paramount was willing to
try making another star trek film but
only if it could be done on a much
smaller budget but despite being made on
the cheap by unproven director nicholas
meyer star trek ii the wrath of khan
made an immediate cultural impact
becoming a legitimate mainstream hit and
winning back eight times its budget the
wrath of khan launched a new prosperous
era in which star trek thrived both on
the big screen and back on television
for another two decades
[Music]
following the success of wrath of khan
star trek became a pop culture brand
that was everywhere spanning movies
television and beyond the original cast
continued to star in feature films
throughout the 80s before hanging it up
in star trek vi the undiscovered country
in 1991 meanwhile trek was undergoing a
renaissance on television with a string
of tv spin-offs that ran for 18
consecutive years and a cumulative 624
episodes star trek the next generation
was a big enough hit to warrant its own
leap to the big screen which kept the
film series alive until the critical and
box office failure of star trek nemesis
in 2002 when trek's television run
likewise came to an end with the
cancellation of star trek enterprise in
2005 the franchise went into stasis for
the first time since the mid-1907
paramount wouldn't let trek rest for too
long in 2007 j.j abrams was officially
attached to direct a new part sequel
part prequel part reboot simply titled
star trek this radical reimagining of
the original source material reignited
mainstream interest in the franchise
making it one of the highest grossing
films of 2009 since then trek has had
two more feature film sequels and yet
another television revival with producer
alex kurtzman now at the helm of the
franchise's five new streaming series
beginning with its first installment in
2000 the x-men franchise was at the
forefront of the superhero movie boom
each chapter of the original x-men
trilogy outgrossed the last raking in a
cumulative billion dollars in worldwide
box office receipts with the original
cast story concluded 20th century fox
sought to expand the franchise with a
variety of new spin-offs beginning with
x-men origins wolverine in 2009
wolverine introduced the characters of
gambit and deadpool to the big screen
and they were each eyed for their own
spin-offs additionally two more prequels
were planned one centered around magneto
and another on charles xavier's original
class of x-men but after the messy
release and critical failure of x-men
origins wolverine 20th century fox put
the rest of their x-men slate on hold
focusing instead on a single project the
prequel film x-men first class which
featured an entirely new cast and a
period setting first class didn't
immediately reverse the franchise's box
office fortunes earning about 10 million
less than x-men origins wolverine on a
similar budget but it was better
received by fans and critics putting the
franchise back in the right direction
its immediate sequel x-men days of
future past combined the new and
original x-men film casts and became a
massive box office hit incidentally days
of future past also erased the poorly
received last stand and origins from
continuity by way of time travel neat
trick huh
1968's planet of the apes is one of the
sci-fi genre's best films as well as the
launch pad of its first long-running
sci-fi film franchises the original
planet of the apes spawned four direct
sequels in rapid succession between 1970
and 1973 and when the series fizzled out
on film the franchise moved to
television first as a live-action series
then in animation but both efforts were
short-lived with the cartoon's
cancellation in 1975 planet of the apes
disappeared from both film and
television for a quarter century a big
budget tim burton helmed reimagining of
planet of the apes was released in 2001
which turned a profit but was such a
critical disaster that the franchise was
immediately put back on the shelf the
next reboot attempt came a decade later
with 2011's prequel rise of the planet
of the apes it gave new life to the
franchise replacing the previous
generation's makeup effects with
remarkably expressive cgi apes performed
via motion capture by the likes of andy
serkis ryze spawned a successful new
apes trilogy whose middle chapter dawn
of the planet of the apes was a critical
darling as well as a smash hit
unsurprisingly another reboot of the
franchise is already in the works
take your sticking pose
damn dirty ape
ridley scott's 1979 sci-fi horror mashup
alien is a classic in both genres so
it's remarkable that anyone was able to
create even one sequel of comparable
quality in the first place james
cameron's 1986 follow-up aliens
triumphed by continuing the journey of
original film protagonist ellen ripley
with a totally different approach in
tone but this trick proved difficult to
repeat 1992's alien 3 distanced itself
from the action-oriented tone of aliens
and was poorly received while 1997's
alien resurrection seemed to
over-correct becoming a bizarre comic
bookie affair that grossed poorly in
north america the brand was kept alive
for a time by crossing over with the
similarly struggling predator franchise
but the alien vs predator film series
likewise fell apart after two entries it
would take ridley scott himself to lend
credibility back to the universe that he
helped create his 2012 film prometheus
is set in the same universe as alien but
follows another set of characters on a
journey that's only tangentially
connected to the events of the original
film more importantly it shares aliens
moody unsettling tone and gruesome body
horror and added even loftier
philosophical and ontological themes
while reviews were mixed prometheus
became the highest grossing film in the
franchise leading to sequel alien
covenant which also serves as a more
direct prequel to the original film with
interest in alien fully revitalized an
additional film and spin-off television
series are forthcoming
godzilla is one of cinema's most
prolific and iconic monsters having
starred in 36 films since 1954 his
longevity as a movie icon has been
assured by his occasionally going into
hibernation as he did in 1975 1995 and
finally in 2004 on the occasion of the
original film's 50th anniversary
japanese studio touhou released godzilla
final wars which brought an end to the
millennium era of godzilla movies and
put the famous kaiju to rest for the
third time a decade later gareth edwards
2014 american godzilla was a critical
and box office success not only did the
2014 godzilla lead to the expansion of
legendary's monsterverse crossing
godzilla over with king kong for the
first time in half a century but also
prompted toho to revive godzilla in
japan godzilla resurgence was not only a
hit at the japanese box office in 2016
but also the recipient of the japan
academy film prize for picture of the
year
the original 1979 mad max is a small
miracle of filmmaking the debut feature
from writer director george miller was
produced for less than half a million
dollars and became such a hit that it
held the world record for the most
profitable film in terms of cost versus
gross until it was toppled by the blair
witch project in 1999 its two sequels
mad max 2 aka the road warrior and mad
max beyond thunderdome were increasingly
expensive and outlandish but also won
increasing financial returns beyond
thunderdome was a hit but was considered
a slight step down in quality from its
predecessors after directing three mad
max films in six years miller was
certain that he was finished with the
series in 1985 but inspiration for fury
road struck hard in 1998 leading to a
torturously long development process the
film was almost made in 2003 then again
in 2010 before cameras finally began
rolling in 2012.
by the time mad max fury road hit
theaters in 2015 the series had been
dormant for 30 years the wait was worth
it fury road was an unqualified critical
and commercial success that earned 10
academy award nominations including best
picture audiences clamored for more and
a franchise was reborn two more mad max
films are currently in development one
featuring series lead max and one
expanding on the origins of the breakout
character of fury road furiosa
there should probably never have been a
sequel to jurassic park in the first
place the moral of the original film is
that a theme park full of sharp-toothed
ravenous prehistoric monsters is a bad
idea that should never be tried again
but try they have over and over again
after the 1993 original came the
underwhelming 1997 sequel the lost world
jurassic park if steven spielberg
himself couldn't make a successful
sequel to his own classic what hope
could anyone else have 2001's jurassic
park 3 was even less successful but
plans for a jurassic park 4 continued to
roll on nevertheless with a decade-long
marathon of rejected scripts
finally in 2015 universal and director
colin trevaro released their
long-awaited big budget attempt to clone
their cash cow jurassic world sporting
an entirely new set of characters but
deeply rooted in nostalgia for the
original jurassic world was a colossal
box office hit raking in over 1.6
billion dollars worldwide and spawning a
pair of sequels of its own like their
genetically reconstituted stars the
jurassic world films really shouldn't
exist but there's no denying that the
franchise is alive and well
from the moment that disney purchased
lucasfilm for 4 billion dollars in 2012
it was a sure thing that star wars would
be coming back to the big screen and
nearly as certain that their first movie
out of the gate would be a smash hit
just as in the case of 1999's the
phantom menace anticipation and
speculation alone would have brought
film goers out in droves to see if the
old star wars magic had come back no
matter how disappointed they may have
been in george lucas's prequel trilogy a
decade earlier what's remarkable about
star wars episode 7 the force awakens
though is the sheer magnitude of its
success it grossed over 936 million
dollars in the us alone and over 2
billion dollars worldwide it also got
the warmest reception from critics of
any star wars film since the empire
strikes back fans may have mixed
feelings as to the overall quality of
the post buyout star wars brand but the
force awakens announced loud and clear
that star wars was back in a big way
it's unlikely to be retired again
anytime soon
the marvel cinematic universe the most
financially successful film franchise of
all time is essentially one big
franchise made of many smaller ones
almost every one of the 23 films in its
ambitious infinity saga won its opening
weekend turned a profit and spawned a
sequel sure all the movies were hit but
answer us this question after thor the
dark world was anybody out there really
clamoring for more solo thor movies the
dark world has the lowest rotten
tomatoes score in the infinity saga and
the first thor doesn't score much higher
with chris hemsworth's original marvel
contract expiring with avengers end game
who's to say there'd have been enough
heat behind the character to renew any
further director taika waititi that's
who why tt took his ailing corner of the
mcu for a hard left turn with thor
ragnarok giving it a new sense of humor
and a new cast of supporting characters
ragnarok outgrossed the dark world
globally by over 200 million dollars and
rests near the top of many lists ranking
the mcu's best films its success
prompted rewrites of avengers infinity
war and the more comedic version of the
character is set to return for another
thor film with waititi at the helm
hemsworth hopes to continue to play thor
for years to come something that almost
certainly wouldn't have happened if not
for ragnarok i thought you were gone
forever i'm glad to see you
you're ruining my disguise
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite sci-fi franchises are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]